for
so I'm going to do overt talking
again so they slide
apart UK tou is slightly always behind
Uchi
tou now is he covering the wrist by 10
cm no so that means that it's not
marshed
it's not the sword
work here he he mustn't feel as if he's
over
leaning does he feel comfortable or does
he feel like he's sitting on a b St s of
sense he used to say don't feel like
you're sitting on a bar stool or else
you can't use your energy to spring back
so if you want to change
over start again the the the Crossovers
too great that's better of the
K start
again right from the beginning that's it
the
crossover got and I'm going to say the
things that I see
incorrect right
so it's and start
again Scott you're moving a little bit
too quick let him sort of absorb you so
it's a feeling like when he moves it's
like a marshmallow or something air
being let out a balloon so he moves and
you move and again better
connection no too jerky
no do it again cal calm yourselves down
take a
breath no and
again no and again it's got to be
smoother it's like letting an air out of
a tile or balloon so it's soft that's
better do it again
Scott your um your in doubts when you
went to lift
it and
again so when it come to cutting the
head you would have nicked the neck but
you wouldn't have taken that whole head
off because you need at least 7 cm of
your Ken past this side of his neck
and finish there